[Music]
Robert Spencer here for Jihad watch a
program of the David harowitz Freedom
Center and for the center for security
policy Ali Akbar hashemi rafsanjani
president of the Islamic Republic of
Iran from 1989 to 1997 died in early
January 2017 and the New York Times was
inconsolable rafen you see was a
reformer a protector according to the
times of what was left of Iran's
marginalized reformist movement and
others with more moderate views than the
conservative Hardline clerics who hold
sway in Iran's security forces and
Judiciary as always reality and with the
New York Times reports couldn't be
farther apart rafen johani said the
times supported Hassan ruhani the
current president who is now suddenly
bereft of a powerful and influential
background figure with Islamic
revolutionary credentials that could not
be questioned without a trace of
self-awareness the times longtime tan
correspondent Thomas erdbrink added in
the very next sentence that Mr rafan
johani was also a longtime comrade of
the supreme leader Ayatollah Ali K
although the two had their disagreements
erdbrink didn't explain how RAF sanani
could be simultaneously a reformer who
supported ruhani and a longtime comrade
of the hardliner K and with good reason
the whole idea a of a reformist movement
within the Iranian regime is a fiction
as Obama adviser Ben rhs himself
revealed to the administration's great
embarrassment in the New York Times
itself in May
2016 that was when the times published
an effusive profile of roads in which
Times Reporter David Samuels revealed
that the way in which most Americans
have heard the story of the Iran deal
presented that the Obama Administration
began seriously engaging with Iranian
officials in 2013 in order to take
advantage of a new political reality in
Iran which came about because of
Elections that brought moderates to
power in that country was largely
manufactured for the purpose of selling
the
deal the chief false and misleading
aspect of Obama's presentation of the
deal to the American public was his
claim that he was dealing with moderate
elements of Iran's Islamic regime that
according to Samuels was a narrative
that roads shaped roads ated the
falsehood that ruhani was a moderate who
was struggling against hardliners within
the regime Samuels describes this as
actively misleading and is as is er
Brink's claim on rafsanjani's death that
he was the chief supporter of this
non-existent reformist movement of which
ruhani was supposedly a part in reality
RAF sanani was just as bellicose
militaristic and intransigent as the
other leaders of the Islamic Republic as
I detail in my book The Complete
infidels guide to Iran on December 22nd
2011 US District Judge George B Daniels
ruled in Havish at all versus Bin Laden
at all that Iran and his balah were
liable for damages to be paid to
relatives of the victims of the
September 11th 2001 Jihad attacks in New
York and Washington as both the Islamic
Republic and its Lebanese proxy had
actively aided al-Qaeda in planning and
executing those attacks Daniels
determined that both K and RAF sanani
were directly implicated in Iranian
efforts to Aid al-Qaeda in the 9/11 plot
now this wasn't the first time that
rafsanjani was implicated in a foreign
Jihad plot on July 18th 1994 a Jihad
martyrdom suicide bomber destroyed the
Jewish Argentine Mutual Association
building in Buenos Iris Argentina
killing 85 people and wounding 300 as
years went by and no one was convicted
of the attack numerous accusations were
made of cover-ups by Argent
investigators and authorities finally in
October 2006 Argentine State prosecutor
Alberto nisman formally charged Iran and
his balah and called for the arrest of
among others RAF sanjani charging that
he had ordered the attack as revenge for
Argentina's ending its nuclear
cooperation with Iran on January 19th
2015 nisman still pursuing this case was
found dead shot to death in his bathtub
RAF sanjani has also spoken cavalierly
about the Islamic Republic of Iran
nuking Israel saying in 2001 that
application of an atomic bomb would not
leave anything in Israel but the same
thing would just produce damages in the
Muslim World in light of Shiite Muslim
prophecies about how the 12th Imam would
return to Earth and proceed to conquer
and islamize the world when Muslims were
persecuted more fiercely than ever
before rafon johani may have been
signaling a willingness to nuke Tel Aviv
in order to provoke a retaliatory
nuclear strike that could kill tens of
millions of Iranians and thereby bring
about the return of the 12th Imam if it
would hasten the mti's coming why not
that was the leader of the reformist
movement in the Islamic Republic of Iran
way do you see the hardliners I'm Robert
Spencer
[Music]